en efecto estas horas han sido cruciales
después de que se conoció que el juez
edwin cruz es el asignado por la corte
suprema de justicia para conocer el caso
de extradición
inmediatamente que se dio a conocer el
nombramiento el juez se empezó a hacer
su etapa de evaluación de trabajo y
recién hace unos minutos ya ha dictado
en primera instancia una orden de
captura es por ello que las fuerzas
militares del país se encuentran en este
momento en el interior de la vivienda de
juan orlando hernández el ex presidente
hondureño ha pedido en extradición por
eeuu como lo había manifestado al inicio
de este día el mismo mandatario en un
audio que publicó en su cuenta de
twitter su entrega según informes del
vocero de la policía ha sido de manera
voluntaria y él estaría siendo
trasladado vía aérea
presumiblemente a uno de los batallones
instalados aquí en tegucigalpa lo que
sigue es
eran sus derechos al expresidente
hondureño y por supuesto este juez que
conoce la causa
iniciara con la etapa del conocimiento
de pruebas que ya han sido públicas y
dadas a conocer por la embajada
americana pues básicamente las
acusaciones y el delito que se le imputa
el más grave es por tráfico ilegal de
drogas a eeuu